hey psychos
together
you know they called us about making
another movie like right after the first
one
and james was said it's got to be a
laster story uh we wanted to bring
everybody back together and
and we wanted a nice a nice serving of
lassie and we wanted to address
everything that had preceded the first
movie at one point there were gonna be
two movies
one was going to be a prequel to the
first movie
[Music]
and then the other one was going to be
the sequel to this which would have been
the most confusing thing we've ever done
uh which is great
trust me on this man you're just really
high high it's basically
it's everything you know about psych is
that everybody has to come back together
to rally around one of their own and
this time it's
lasser which brings us back to santa
barbara
and it's how this affects
everybody and at some point we were like
oh right we have to
thread a mystery through all these
things that we want to do and so we just
started ripping pages out of old books
and pasting them into the script nobody
noticed
that like the pages were different
colors and the fonts weren't matching
to be clear they were books for young
readers
it was fun because we just wanted to
come hang out we just gone through so
much
there's a new level of energy everyone
got to sort of have that time to just
really be present and take it all in and
be with him and it was awesome it was so
fun the gift you gave me by
restructuring the script so i could be
such a part of it is
something i can never pay you for you
prepaid us tenfold just think about how
many times i've seen you naked come on
i'm so turned on right now dude
we laugh we make jokes we have all these
fun moments it's why we're all here
still here
gonna make four more movies six eight
i still say i want to see sean at 60.
we like to make plans and then we blow
them up
what is wrong with youtube pearson got a
pilot peggy got a pilot before we shoot
unfortunately kirsten was shooting in
town
maggie shot a couple days at the
beginning and then
left and learned a new role and shot an
entire other pilot and then came back
the rule on psych is if anybody has a
better opportunity
then we have to figure out a way for all
of them to work out so
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa there's never a
better opportunity to psych
[Laughter]
she was very pregnant and we mostly
were super creative and hid the bump
steve and i had backup plans
for if she went into labor after jasmine
did her first day of
shooting it was like if she goes to the
labor tonight and i'll just rewrite this
thing all right so she just doesn't get
in the car and she doesn't go to the
second half of the movie
but if she shot the second day she had
to shoot the third day
we were worried it was gonna happen but
what we didn't take into account is
if she had gone into labor delay wasn't
gonna stay anyway
so we wouldn't have to really figure out
a new way
we've got a great lineup of awesome
super
funny good humans uh assembled for
for the next one our buddy sarah chalk
now i know
this goofy little white guy sexy black
dude routine the two of you have going
like the back of my scrubs
kadeem hardison i see it jack daddy
just a a good sport and a great guy a
million little things allison miller
makes an appearance
do your parents know you're doing this
what how old do you think i am
41. 41. jimmy simpson is back
reprising the world mary lightly burp
full of the curtfolio
that goes without saying woody the
mustache is spectacular from my lip to
god's ears
sage bronco bank of course uh
buzz you look big and slick sean gosh
what are you guys doing in santa barbara
and don't forget richard schiff
i'm dr herschel this is my facility
those
are my ice chips we're sorry we're just
we're both fans of delicious flavor
one of the main highlights for me was
the sweet sweet joel mchale
we had tim believing that this very
pivotal role in the life of lassiter was
going to be played by a rock-solid
but local theater actor and joel gave us
a name that he wanted us to use what we
put on the call sheet
paul gerk paulgirth that was the name it
was a no-brainer for him i think the
only concern at the very beginning was
can we pull this off to not tell tim
before
and have this be like an actual surprise
on
set on the day just about every day tim
was asking
who's going to play this role who's
going to play this role and he was
relentless he wouldn't say
amongst all the other challenges on this
movie that was probably
in the top five joel walks in and your
face
it was really a fantastic moment
i think what i'm most excited for
everybody to see in this movie is an
example of how my dear friends all just
rallied around me
everywhere you turned they were making
accommodations for me and carrying me
through this thing
i'll tell you something for all the
shows i've done over the years and all
the
moments on any set probably watching you
tim figure your way back
was one of the most inspiring things
i've ever seen i think it defined who we
were as a show it probably will be
one of the highlights of my career just
being on a set with you watching you
the bravery the courage and
determination to find your way back
we didn't expect on our side to to get
that gift
to to watch you like you know
jesse owens running around the track
which is cheering for you and it's it's
pretty amazing
he's a tough man with the thick skin of
a northern white rhino but
the heart of a smaller less white rhino
you know the movie coming out this
summer is his
emotional and serious as we've done
and it's just silly and ridiculous as
we've done and it's all mixed up in the
strange
stew that is our show psych two lassie
come home that title sounds like you
made it up right this second
coming this summer summer
peacock exactly what i said
you